einer Paule der eigentlich nicht so ein
richtiger Experte ist ist ja Dieter
Bohlen und der hat ziemlich für Furore
gesorgt weil mir doch einmal rein
aber ich bin eben der Meinung
wir sind ihr könnt mich ruhig ausruhen
ja aber wenn die diese Sanktionen zum
Beispiel nicht gemacht hätten und man
hätte sich vernünftig an einen Tisch
gesetzt ja dann bräuchten die Leute sich
jetzt nicht den ganzen Firlefanz machen
ja die Leute jetzt müssen wir frieren
jetzt müssen wir dies und das das ist
doch alles scheiße von aus meiner Sicht
ja man kann das jetzt sehen okay mit dem
kriechen Ukraine man kann das immer
alles aber ich meine alles was da so
passiert und das Russland jetzt für viel
viel mehr Geld Gast nach Asien verkauft
und das ist ja ich meine das verstehe
ich alles nicht mehr jetzt
Paul wie ordnest du die Aussage von
Dieter Bohlen ein du hast ja auch mit
Wladimir Klitschko ein Interview dazu
geführt
aus meiner Sicht ist
Dieter Bohlen dort auf russische
Propaganda reingefallen so klar muss man
das sagen also zunächst einmal
diejenigen die gegen Sanktionen
argumentieren die müssen zu Wort kommen
und es ist auch wichtig dass es diese
Debatte gibt über Sinnhaftigkeit oder
nicht Sinnhaftigkeit von Sanktionen aber
die Art und Weise wie Dieter Bohlen über
diesen Krieg spricht über Wladimir Putin
spricht auch über die Ukraine spricht
die weiß doch auf dass er sich damit
offenbar nicht wirklich beschäftigt hat
fangen wir mit den Verhandlungen an also
Dieter Bohlen sagt es habe ja gar keine
Verhandlungen gegeben und man hätte sich
ja einfach mal an einen Tisch setzen
können das ist faktisch falsch vor dem
Krieg haben so will ja Emmanuel macron
als auch Olaf Scholz und andere ist
versucht mit Wladimir Putin ins Gespräch
zu kommen diese beiden an einen Tisch zu
bekommen es gibt sogar Aussagen von
russischen offiziellen die in
amerikanischen Medien zitiert werden die
sagen Wladimir Putin wollte all das vor
dem Krieg nicht hören man muss immer
wieder sagen er wollte diesen Krieg er
hat geglaubt dass er hier die Ukraine
überrennen kann dass die Menschen ihm
zujubeln und er hat die Existenz der
Ukraine in Frage gestellt das zweite ist
er sagt dass die Sanktionen nichts
bringen würden also er verallgemeinert
sehr spricht da den Rubel unter anderem
an was richtig ist der Rubel ist nicht
so
runtergefallen wie Experten oder wie
auch Europa das gehofft hatte aber
bringen deshalb alle Sanktionen nichts
nein gerade wenn man sich bestimmte
Wirtschaftsbereiche anschaut die
sensiblen Bereiche also insbesondere die
Frage von Waffenlieferungen russland hat
große Probleme jetzt Chips zu bekommen
also sozusagen dieses Thema weiter
auszubauen das ist nur eine von vielen
Dingen die man in dem
hochtechnologiebereich sieht wo die
Sanktionen sehr wohl etwas bringen und
diese Isolation auch vielen vielen große
Sorgen macht auch wenn man die gesamten
Wirtschaftsdaten anschaut das dritte ist
Dieter Bohlen sagt man muss diesen Krieg
beenden ja natürlich muss man diesen
Krieg be dann aber wer kann den Krieg
beenden Wladimir Putin nämlich indem er
sagt raus aus der Ukraine Truppen raus
und der Krieg wäre beendet also ich
glaube dass das sehr gefährlich ist vor
allem wie Dieter Bohlen hier formuliert
hat
Herr Schindler paronsheimer sagt es ist
sehr gefährlich wie Dieter Bohlen hier
argumentiert hat wie sehen Sie das also
im großen und ganzen Teil ist die
Auffassung die Herr Ronzheimer hier
vertreten hat
es ist allerdings so dass wir schon
darauf achten müssen dass wir uns nicht
instrumentalisieren lassen weder von der
Ukraine noch von beispielsweise den
US-Amerikanern wir müssen eine aktive
Friedenspolitik betreiben und die
bedeutet wir müssen immer wieder
innehalten und sagen kann das so
weitergehen wie es gerade läuft und da
bin ich der Auffassung dass Menschen wie
Bowlen etwas zum Ausdruck bringen was
sicherlich noch stärker werden wird
nämlich eine gewisse Unzufriedenheit mit
dieser Entwicklung weil man kein Ende
sieht und wer kein hier sieht weiß nicht
was er macht und wenn ich weiß was er
macht der ist unsicher diese
Unsicherheit die gilt es zu beseitigen
da können wir heute Abend ja ein Stück
weit drüber reden Frau Weidenfeld sehen
sie auch kein Ende in Sicht ja ich sehe
vor allem kein Ende in Sicht in einer
gewissen Haltung die den Krieg als als
einzige Möglichkeit sieht oder immer
weitere Aufrüstung und ich denke es muss
auch auch im intellektuellen Milieu ein
Fundament geschaffen werden dass man
andere Optionen einfach aufmacht was
wäre für sie so eine Option also Krieg
will ja eigentlich niemand ich kann mir
kaum vorstellen dass jemand Krieg möchte
das heißt was wäre die Option wie könnte
man Wladimir Putin einen Tisch bekommen
also ich bin jetzt kein militär-experte
aber sagen ich rede jetzt hier als
Kulturwissenschaftlerin und da denke ich
ist es ganz wichtig dass wir
runterkommen von möglichen Projektionen
sie sagen wir dürfen uns nicht
beeinflussen lassen weder von
ukrainischer noch von russischer Seite
ich denke mal Kriegspropaganda gibt es
wahrscheinlich auf beiden Seiten
das Russland den Angriffskrieg geführt
hat und im Unrecht ist darüber sind wir
uns alle einig aber es das ist meine
Diagnose ist findet es finden alle
möglichen Idealisierungen und
Projektionen statt gerade leider auch
bei vielen intellektuellen nicht alle
aber viele und das ist gefährlich denn
gerade auch intellektuelle haben eine
gewisse Macht die beanspruchen sie auch
für sich dass Sie wissen wo es lang geht
und wir müssen da runterkommen und die
Realität sehen am Krieg ist erstmal
wenig heldenhaftes sondern wir haben es
ja gerade gesehen wir haben also
Verständnis für Dieter Bohlen grauen ach
Dieter Bohlen redet immer so wie in der
Schnabel gewachsen ist also ich würde es
jetzt nicht überbewerten und das jetzt
gerade als Zeichen sehen dass er von der
russischen Seite jetzt indoktriniert
worden ist sondern einfach mal wieder
blöd locker formuliert ich würde dann
nicht mehr in eine interpretieren eine
Frage ich würde gerne noch einmal
peronsheimer dazu der uns auch weiterhin
zugeschaltet ist Paul gerade wurde
gesagt dass es auch Propaganda
Kriegspropaganda von beiden Seiten geben
würde wie würdest du das einordnen
ich finde das erstmal sozusagen eine ja
Verniedlichung der der russischen Seite
denn erstmal muss man sagen und dass das
was ich als Reporter erlebt habe das hat
Grausamkeiten auf der russischen Seite
zu Tage gefördert ich war ein Butcher
als die Menschen dort auf der Straße
lagen Zivilisten noch mit den Händen
verbunden auf dem Rücken erschossen ich
war in den foltergefängnissen in isum im
Osten des Landes ich war mit Menschen
dort die dort gefoltert wurden die mir
berichtet haben wie Elektroschocks
eingesetzt wurden andere Menschen die
Schreie gehört haben Massengräber die
dort die ist dort gibt also man muss
einmal festhalten in allen befreiten
Gebieten in denen ich war nachdem das
passiert ist überall kamen diese Groll
Taten zu Tage und jedes Ort jeder Ort
der jetzt noch besetzt ist von den
Russen da müssen wir davon ausgehen das
sind diesen Minuten wo wir reden in
die Menschen gefoltert werden und das
ist der große Unterschied muss man sagen
zu dem was in ukrainischen Regionen
passiert die Ukraine ist eine Demokratie
auch wenn immer versucht wird sozusagen
sie in irgendeine Richtung zu rücken
natürlich hat die Ukraine als Staat auch
große Probleme gehabt aber wir können
das ganze nicht gleichsetzen das ist
glaube ich sehr wichtig und was
Propaganda angeht der große Unterschied
ist wir dürfen hier frei berichten ich
war im Gebieten und habe zum Beispiel
aufgedeckt auch auf ukrainischer Seite
als das ukrainische
Verteidigungsministerium davon
gesprochen hat das bestimmte Dinge dort
vorgefallen sind da ging es um Zähne die
angeblich dort gefangenen entrissen sein
sollen da haben wir aufgedeckt dass das
eben nicht der Fall ist wir können aber
frei recherchieren wir können mit den
Menschen sprechen in Russland gibt es
ausschließlich staatliche Propaganda
Fernsehsender die eben nur berichten was
Putin sehen will und ich glaube diese
Unterschiede muss man immer wieder ganz
ganz klar machen und ich bin ehrlicher
ehrlicherweise glücklich das ist viele
Menschen gibt und das ist auch viele
Intellektuelle gibt die das klar sehen
klar ansprechen und auch klar
aussprechen das hat nichts damit zu tun
dass irgendjemand kriegt will ich als
jemand der seit über zehn Jahren Krieg
gesehen hat
kann Ihnen das ganz sicher sagen niemand
möchte das was wir hier erleben irgendwo
sehen
wenn Sie das Hören auch die Worte von
parents haben auch von den Gräueltaten
und sie waren ja verteidigungspolitische
Sprecher der SPD was kann die deutsche
Regierung denn tun
vor allem muss man sich klar machen
warum wollen wir denn die Ukraine
überhaupt unterstützen und das eine eine
Reihe von Gründen hat ja Paul ronsheimer
eben schon ausgeführt einfach aufgrund
der gewaltigen Ungerechtigkeiten und
Verbrechen die dort begangen worden sind
aber es gibt auch einen globalen Aspekt
was bedeutet es eigentlich für unser
aller Sicherheit wenn eine Großmacht wie
Russland sich damit durchsetzte ihre
Ziele erreicht dass sie einen
Angriffskrieg führt also praktisch das
größte Verbrechen begeht das in den
Beziehungen zwischen Völkern und Staaten
überhaupt möglich ist und sich dann auch
noch durchsetzt in dem sie mit dem
Einsatz von Atomwaffen droht was was
löst das weltweit aus was für Lehren
werden da ausgezogen für Russland ganz
klar wenn das einmal geklappt hat wird
es auch wieder klappen also wenn man
jetzt beispielsweise ein
Waffenstillstand hätte dann hätte
Russland einen Sieg errungen es hätte
eine Landbrücke hergestellt zwischen den
bereits besetzten Gebieten im
donetzbecken und der Krim es hätte ein
Fünftel der Ukraine besetzt sind dann
Aufmarschgebiet gewonnen für den
nächsten Krieg und es hat ja gelernt
wenn wir nur hart genug vorgehen wenn
wir nur streng genug drohen scharf genug
drohen dann knicken die anderen ein
irgendwann wollen sie an
Waffenstillstand und wir schneiden
wieder ein Scheibchen von der Ukraine ab
das ist keine Ukraine mehr gibt aber
nicht nur Russland würde ja dieser
Konsequenzen ziehen sondern Diktatoren
Aggressoren weltweit würden lernen wie
man das macht wenn man nur hart genug
auftritt wenn man nur mit genug
Vernichtung droht und ultimative
Vernichtung ist ja die Atomwaffen
verstehen sie denn die Sorgen der Bürger
auch in Deutschland bei uns ich verstehe
die Sorgen absolut ich mache mir nur
Sorgen ob es nicht noch alles für
unsicherer und gefährlicher wird
weltweit wenn wir jetzt an dieser Stelle
ist nicht schaffen das Stoppschild
aufzurichten und zu sagen bis hierhin
und nicht weiter diese Art miteinander
umzugehen in den Beziehungen zwischen
Völkern und Staaten die haben wir nach
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg für alle Zeiten
verbannen wollen von unserem Planeten
und jetzt kommt die zurück und das
können wir nicht zulassen Herr Frost
sind sie auch für der Stoppschild ich
bin tatsächlich ein bisschen
bei Frau Weinfeld und ich finde auch so
die Aussagen von der Bohlen sollte man
jetzt nicht auf die Goldwaage legen er
redet halt wie in der Mund gewachsen ist
und ich glaube Herr Bohlen sagt eben das
was viele ich zum Beispiel auch und
viele aus der gesellschaftlichen Mitte
glaube ich befürchten dass die ganze
Sache einfach sich immer weiter zuspitzt
und
gefühlt hört man natürlich eine Position
ich gefühlt höre die Position
Waffenlieferungen Waffen lief morgen
Waffenlieferungen
und das ist vor allem um die Wirtschaft
Sanktionen ja auch weiß ich nicht das
kann ich ganz schwer bewerten
inwieweit sowas greift aber ich würde es
auch schön finden wenn man auch noch mal
sich überlegt ob man sich dann nicht an
Tisch setzen kann
tatsächlich für mich gefühlt Spitze ich
das auch sehr hart zu und man hört halt
immer wir müssen mehr Waffen liefern und
ich weiß nicht ob das der richtige Weg
ist weil natürlich mehr Waffen aus
meiner Sicht verlängern den Krieg und
damit auch so das Leid der Menschen also
wenn ich zusammenfasse haben Sie
eigentlich Angst dass Deutschland jetzt
aktiver Teilnehmer hineingezogen wird
also ich bin überzeugt dass sie mir den
Faktor schon wenn wir auch gerade auf
Cyberattacken gucken dann sind wir aktiv
beteiligt und ich als ganz normaler sind
wir beteiligt was Cyber-Attacken
betrifft es gibt und und gab viele
seilbahnattacken auch auf öffentliche
Einrichtungen das Fraunhofer Institut
war vor kurzem Thema Verwaltungen und
ich bin mir sicher dass ich das auch
noch zuspitzen wird tatsächlich
und auch wenn wir über Waffenlieferungen
reden finde ich
ist ist man natürlich beteiligt
automatisch
man ist nicht Kriegsparteien nur weil
man Waffen liefert aber ich weiß was sie
meint aber ja man spricht das nicht aus
aber natürlich
unterstützt man damit den Krieg auch
finde ich also ich habe so ein bisschen
so ein bisschen Sorge dass mehr Waffen
auch mehr Leid bedeuten hier würde ich
einmal ganz gerne kurz eine kurze
Einschätzung noch mal vor ein paar
Ronzheimer haben weil das beschäftigt
wirklich und da haben sie vollkommen
Recht ganz viele Menschen in diesem Land
wie ob es möglich ist wie es möglichst
Putin an den Tisch zu bekommen und wenn
man hört einfach ein Tisch setzen ist es
denn überhaupt möglich Paul wie sieht es
da aus
also erstmal muss ich noch einmal ganz
kurz sagen es ist das Gegenteil ist hier
der Fall in der Ukraine
die Waffen die wir liefern sorgen für
weniger Leid insbesondere was eben die
Zivilisten angeht in diesem Raum in den
ich war im Osten des Landes in anderen
Teilen des Landes die befreit werden die
befreit werden von Russland die diese
Menschen terrorisieren die diese
Menschen und die ukrainische Kultur
zerstören wollen und das teilweise tun
da findet eine Befreiung statt und da
kann man nicht sagen weil wir den Waffen
liefern wird es da schlimmer nein in den
Regionen gerade was auch die deutschen
Waffen angeht nämlich die
Luftverteidigung zum Beispiel die
eingesetzt wird um russische Raketen
abzufangen das bedeutet das ist weniger
Leid gibt hier in der Ukraine das ist
mir ganz wichtig zu sagen was
Verhandlungen angeht man muss das auch
immer wieder ganz klar machen würde mir
selenski war von Anfang an das Krieges
und vor dem Krieg immer
mit Wladimir Putin zu sprechen aber was
jetzt passiert ist in den vergangenen
drei Wochen in den vergangenen Monaten
erstens klare Kriegsverbrechen zweitens
gab es die Fake Referenten wladimir
Putin hat gesagt ja diese Regionen die
gehören jetzt Russland und darüber ist
auch nicht mehr zu reden und er hat dann
eine nuklear Drohung ausgesprochen wenn
es zu einem Erfolg führt das Vladimir
Putin ähm mit diesen Drohungen und
diesen Äußerungen dann sagt okay ich
kriege das was ich will und da gebe ich
dann Herrn felgentor recht dann bedeutet
das auch eine Gefahr für die gesamte
Weltordnung denn das würde bedeuten ein
Land wie Russland kann ein anderes
erpressen und bekommt dann das was es
will momentan ist die Lage so dass die
Ukraine ganz unabhängig von den Raketen
Angriffen die es auf Kiew gab und andere
Städte gab an der Front gewinnt da gab
es
Gebietsgewinne die immens sind in den
vergangenen Monaten Dinge die man der
Ukraine nicht zugetraut hat und die
Ukraine souveräner Staat sagt wir werden
es dann verhandeln wenn die russischen
Truppen aus dem Land sind und
mittlerweile sagt man auch erst dann
wenn es einen neuen Präsidenten gibt
wenn Wladimir Putin dort nicht mehr ist
da weiß ich nicht ob das so schlau ist
dass sozusagen da bin ich Indifferenz
allerdings verstehe ich es dass ein Land
sagt nein wir sind nicht bereit Teile
unseres Landes Orte den Russen zu
überlassen das wäre so als würde ein
fremdes Land Deutschland überfallen und
wir sagen okay Stuttgart und München
sind vielleicht doch nicht ganz so
wichtig die bekommt dann dieses Land das
ist die Realität
danke für deine Einschätzung Paul wir
kommen jetzt zu der These von ihnen Frau
Weidenfeld heute abend
erstmal Antworten zu sagen militärisch
zu äußern obwohl ich das überhaupt nicht
vorhatte von wegen ja
Verhandlungsbereitschaft es geht ja so
ein Gerücht jetzt kam es ja gerade
wieder vor von einem Experten das ist ja
durchaus Pläne gab im April ein
Vorschlag und angeblich soll also
Johnson reingestürmt sein vielleicht
weiß es noch der expendé aus
geheimquellen und gesagt jetzt ist nicht
die Zeit wir Verhandlungen ja also
erstmal ist die Frage wer verhandelt ist
es die Ukraine oder ziehen da
möglicherweise die USA im Hintergrund
die Strippen dass wir die eine Frage die
ich gern Paul zurückgeben möchte und das
andere ist
ja ist die Ukraine wirklich so
verhandlungsbereit also
tut mir leid diese Logik mehr Waffen
weniger leid
vielleicht bin ich alles
Kulturwissenschaftlerin da einfach zu
blöd also kapiere es nicht also selensky
hat ja mal gesagt vor einigen Monaten
ich will keine Rückeroberung der Krim
das würde 100.000 Tote bedeuten
ja geben wir also die beiden Fragen
einfach mal direkt dann zurück Frau
ronsheim ist es ja zugeschaltet ja also
ich kann es ganz praktisch ganz
praktisch erklären mehr Waffen weniger
Leid warum wenn es die Luftverteidigung
Iris t die zum Beispiel gerade geliefert
wurde von Deutschland hier in Kiew schon
gegeben hätte
wäre Oksana nicht gestorben wäre Oksana
nicht von dieser Rakete getroffen worden
und ihr kleiner Sohn hätte noch eine
Mutter so klar und deutlich kann man das
beantworten
darf das erinnert mich so ein bisschen
an Trump wissen Sie wie der
schulvorfall war wo ein Attentäter in
der Schule über zehn Kinder erschossen
hatte hat Trump gesagt hätten wir die
Lehrer alle bewaffnet wäre das nicht
passiert
das ist eine Logik dürfen wir nicht
akzeptieren die dürfen wir nicht
akzeptieren herunter immer sondern unser
Ziel muss sein auch ohne Waffenlieferung
Frieden
ist
Menschen gerettet hätte sorry das ist
doch absurd
wenn man hier eine Luftverteidigung
aufgebaut hätte seit vielen Wochen und
Monaten dann hätten diese Raketen diese
Menschen nicht getroffen so einfach ist
die Wahrheit und kommen Sie mir doch
damit nicht mit Donald Trump was hat das
denn mit Donald Trump zu tun
das hat nichts mit Donald Trump zu tun
sondern es hat mit der Logik der
Argumentation zu tun Waffen sind keine
Frieden stiftende Aktion und es gibt
auch nicht den Kontakt
natürlich
aber das ist ja genau das was ich so man
nimmt jetzt ein eine Aussage von Dieter
Bohlen die übrigens glaube ich wirklich
widerspiegelt was viele denken und
interpretiert da jetzt so mega viel rein
es gibt irgendwie gefühlt aus der Mitte
gibt es zwei Positionen Waffen
Friedensverhandlungen aber es gibt ja
noch viel dazwischen was da irgendwie
machen kann und das finde ich ein
bisschen schade dass also ich habe das
Gefühl es sind so zwei ganz verhärtete
Fronten ich möchte gerne einmal noch
ganz kurz dabei bleiben bei der bei der
Sache die paronsheim erklärt hat und
wohin andere Meinung war Herr Felgentreu
als ehemaliger Sprecher ja
wie sehen Sie das denn also was Herr
Horns haben wir gerade erklärt hat da
müssen wir schon einmal bei bleiben weil
er hier große Unterschiede da in der in
der Logik verstehung herrschen wie
würden sie es denn einschätzen
die Ukraine hat die Wahl sich zu
verteidigen das kann sie nur wenn wir
die Waffen dafür geben denn die
ukrainische Rüstung sind Industrie ist
größer als größtenteils durch russische
Raketenangriffe zerstört worden und sie
war auch nie so stark dass sie alleine
in der Lage gewesen wäre diese
verteidigungsanstrengung zu tragen aber
wenn wir die Waffen nicht geben dann
bleibt der Ukraine nur die Erfüllung der
russischen Kriegsziele das heißt es gibt
dann zwar irgendeine Art von Frieden
aber das wäre natürlich eine
Friedhofsruhe in der Ukraine ist würde
dann diese freie russische diese freie
ukrainische Regierung nicht mehr geben
man hätte dann entweder eine Ukraine als
besetzten basalen Stadt der Russen oder
gar keine Ukraine mehr das wäre die
Alternative und es gab am Anfang etliche
Experten die gesagt haben Russland nimmt
Kiew und die Ukraine in wenigen Tagen
ein oder nicht ja ich habe das immer für
etwas naiv gehalten ich bin seit 2013
der für den Bereich der ehemaligen
Sowjetunion zuständige Berichterstatter
in der SPD-Fraktion im
Verteidigungsausschuss gewesen bin also
mehrfach in die Region gereist und habe
beobachtet wie sich die Kampfkraft und
die Moral der ukrainischen Streitkräfte
verändert hatte in den letzten acht
Jahren deswegen war mir relativ klar
dass die ein wesentlich unangenehmerer
Gegner für die Russen werden würden als
das so Land dort landläufig verbreitet
waren das allerdings die Russen so
schwach sein würden mit ihrem Angriff
das habe ich auch nicht erwartet nur
dieses dieses Szenario in drei Tagen
sind wir in Kiew das habe ich immer für
naiv gehalten